hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to three scary games the
video where I play three scary games and
then you watch me play three scary games
and when I'm done with those three scary
games I will then review the three scary
games giving you my thoughts
cabin let's start this game or start the
show as it's saying you know kind of a
show we're gonna see but it's going to
be an interesting shot I wonder where I
should Park
don't want to venture in too far I'll
need some place to put my tent
there's a trail
what's the sign say
what the heck was that
I loved that opening it was so quick and
so dry and the delivery the delivery was
like someone uh like Max Payne level
delivery like that narration and that's
not a bad thing this road this road is
long it's really dark out it's snowing
I'm driving ungripping the wheel I'm
looking at a sign that's assigned to a
trail I can't read it I take my eyes off
the road oh [ __ ] I swerve I hit a tree I
better open the door I'm unbuckling my
seat belts wow the mouse doesn't do my
tires
you should what
you should chain your tires or you
should check your tires because those
are two different things
should get the gear from the bed of my
truck and camp for the night I'll worry
about this in the morning
I'm opening the back of the truck I'm
grabbing my gear out of the back I
should probably when I get it go to the
campsite and set up my tent when I set
up my tent I should probably get inside
of it I better put my sleeping bag
inside of it who knows what had happened
if I didn't I'm closing the bed of my
truck not bothering to lock it not even
gonna close the door what's the point
life is so meaningless colors don't even
have any vibrancy anymore where's the
North Star there's no North Star to turn
off the truck
ah turns out that I'm smart after all
better turn off the truck better close
the door better do all these maintenance
things
Stacy once you leave it's dark now good
thing I got that flashlight hope there's
no monsters in the woods would be
awfully serendipitous for me to die at
this point I should go to that trail I
saw earlier
you're right I saw a trail the one that
made me crash I'm gonna beat the [ __ ]
out of that sign uh sign did you tasty
the same communal cabin up ahead this
must be one of those cabins that hikers
share I gotta check it out
I don't like the sound of a communal
cabin
that sounds just all kinds of terrifying
man what's dark
all right you know I met I made fun of
it before but now it's just calling me
out on me it's dark this Trail is narrow
that was a wolf howl I'm startled that
what the f what kind of luck or am I
seeing things no that was a lumberjack
that was very clearly a lumberjack with
an ax I saw the Red Flannel I thought I
saw the like leather or brown coat
I saw boots tromping through the woods
that was a lumberjack probably out of
big beard it's the cabin right there oh
oh looks like somebody's inside already
time to barge on in hello
you're sleeping in air
huh sure would be on there if somebody
and it's getting colder out here
someone must be using the cabin
the fire's on maybe they left firewood
it sure would explain the Lumberjack
that I should just go inside I'm sure
they won't mind since the weather's
getting bad
foreign
I think I'm just shaken out from the
tire blowing out on me
suck on me
hmm
which one do I want oh give me that dark
chocolate baby
didn't know this is going to be a Choose
Your Own Adventure kind of deal
okay interesting ah heroin
someone doing drugs over here that
doesn't seem too good
hmm
well this is awfully quaint
lovely even let me just read all their
personal stuff you know just hope they
don't mind
I don't know what that is oh
oh oops wait you're Jessica I I didn't I
didn't know that you weren't gonna read
I thought that meant
never mind I'm sorry I haven't been
really in touch with you I've been busy
doing the hunt with the deputy for this
monster how are the kids tell them that
Daddy says hi and I'll be back home
shortly love you Jason
Stacy God damn it Stacy
boogie man something's outside
well
I'm okay ah let's open it
oh that other hiker
hey how you doing over there
yeah definitely don't shine the light
out first pointed right at the ground oh
God
that's not good
all right I guess oh I I am playing this
but my mouse isn't working oh I'm just
going forward oh okay
I'm like on Rails here this is weird
didn't expect that
yeah this is this is good
oh God whoa
that's a dead Burr
that is a dead Burr what do I do I can't
go forward anymore
oh my goodness oh what
geez my my dark chocolate
yeah I gotta go man I gotta go I'm
crawling on my belly
what is happening
what is happening
oh wow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not what I was expecting
but I get what it said by start the show
the only choice I had in that game was
chocolate or almond I mean not
bad but not really a game it was a
pseudo-interactive experience
and it had some odd moments I felt like
they just wanted to make that last
segment a cut scene
but they were like oh [ __ ] if we make it
a cutscene then there's not really
anything for the player to do
so they had to make it playable I I'll
leave it at that I don't want to get too
nitpicky about it because there is some
potential air and obviously I I can
recognize when someone went into this
with a vision and I think that's what
the developer did they went in with a
specific vision and they didn't
absolutely know how they were going to
execute it but they wanted to execute it
as true to that Vision as possible and I
totally get that I get that and I
respect that however there are many
shortfalls so I'll leave it at that and
we'll move on to the next one okay this
one is called scp-091 nostalgia
now the thing is I don't remember what
scp-091 is what's with the
oh
yeah I don't really remember what
scp-091 was
I don't know what the story is for this
game I don't know the scenario with
which we're here and I don't remember
any kind of containment procedures for
scp-091 I could have looked up but I
wanted to see if it would tell the story
as I played it I don't know what the
purple lines are all about
what's going on there oh
is this important
Scotty's the tissue for any issue
okay oh
what's going on with the purple whoa
sound awfully Majestic box of tissues
[Music]
oh
what oh
oh wait oh
okay oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh
tissue
I got it I got a tissue I got it
oh let me just pick up these tissues
here
oh
I have is scp-091a box of tissues a box
of anomalous tissues
that's really creepy I don't even know
why why is that inherently creepy were
there any tissues up here that I've
missed
[Laughter]
when did when did the floor change I
didn't even notice that okay there was
oh yeah I got it oh there's one over
here too
okay
great I'm missing one so there's one
more tissue somewhere oh tissue I see it
oh wait what the frick there's more
tissues what
10 tissues
11 of 10.
12 of 10 ah
a bonanza of tissues
who knew that I could have so many
I was not prepared for it okay let's go
outside what's the deal here
oh test subject did not escape the test
from the test subject's mine was lost to
the Nostalgia inducing properties of
scp-091 test subject remains alive but
every memory has been replaced by
memories of Scotty's brand tissue boxes
the sap Containment Breach needs your
help what did I do wrong
hey come on now
wait a minute
wait so was I supposed to
collect the tissues
or weird weird
I don't remember this one at all that's
the thing about these SCP games you
could make a million SCP games there are
so many different scps out there
and someone made a game about a box of
tissues someone made an SCP about a box
of tissues like that's fascinating
okay so I got 10 of 10. now the question
is is there anything I can do with the
10 of 10.
hey I'm
sure maybe maybe the problem is because
I went up and down I legitimately like
from the wait why is that green now
oh
oh
subject test test subject past the
subject appeared to be affected by
scp-091 for most of the session subject
to successfully retained memory Insanity
levels enough after the session to find
the exit door of the testing room this
episode will be used for further tests
on other scps
[Applause]
oh that's funny I I feel like that one
was uh put together in a hurry to uh
help out the SCP Foundation for their
legal troubles which I made a video
about a little bit ago but you know I
like it I like it I'm into that I'm down
for that I'm oh I'm a sucker for SCP
games I'm a sucker I'm a sucker for him
so I like it it is not possible to save
progress as the game only lasts 10 to 15
minutes oh all right then this one's
called true nightmares chapter one
well there's a man who has many a
nightmare I'm gonna see how true these
really are I'm going to take a shower I
need the towel in my room upstairs this
is a weird thing to declare as I walk in
my front door you'd think that I would
know where my dowel was as I shout to
myself but alas sometimes
I try to keep myself Company by hearing
my own Echo as it reverberates off the
walls
you'd think that I would keep a towel in
my
bathroom but apparently no
hello
wait
what
wait oh God I thought did my bedroom
door just not open enough it's locked
the keys somewhere downstairs
go to the bathroom and place it on the
towel rack
God I'm a real stickler for protocol
when it comes to my showers
you doing all right time to get naked
and scrub a dub dub
all the water all at once I'm an
efficient man get me wet and get me out
all right dry off when am I not even
gonna use the towel a lot of a lot of
hoot Spa about that towel and I'm not
even gonna use it press F to toggle the
flashlight on the smartphone turn off
all the lights in the house and put this
cell phone in the dresser
I'm sorry what
I'm sorry what I'm sorry what all right
I gotta make sure I don't waste power I
suppose also there's apparently a key
somewhere down here
this is the wimpiest light I've ever
seen in my life well I'm not a big fan
of traipsing around my house in the dark
but so far not so bad Tutti Frutti wow
okay so supposedly there's a key
somewhere around here
I don't know where
oh there
I don't need this now what do you mean
you don't need this now what do you mean
you don't need this now all right fine
I'll just turn off all my gosh darn
lights at least I know where that is you
think I would have turned them off on
the way oh oh it's a broom closet I
thought it was just a black wall
interesting
home sweet home yeah you deserve to be
haunted
555.12 what kind of telephone has a
radio on it okay whatever all right good
night
God this is the worst who would do this
to themselves who would turn off all the
lights and then walk back upstairs I
hate it you sprint you sprint as fast as
you can so the demons can't grab your
ankles I'm spitting
yeah
okay
I need to turn off all the lights before
leaving my smartphone yeah yeah yeah
there we go
what what light is on there's not a
there's not a light on uh
uh
in here oh I'm sorry my upstairs Den
office
whatever was that the last one are we
gonna be nice now
there we go
you're on a rama time to get my snooze
on no one crushes sleep like I do I'm a
winner baby what am I looking at I like
to sleep eyes open at the door so no one
dares come in my room at night I'll
strangle them with my own feet
as I Slumber away I'm gonna strangle
these dreams choke them out hello
oh
this is not my room
ah
this makes sense
okay
all right cool
I need to find the key well I had a key
but I said to myself that I didn't need
it now
which lo and behold looks like I might
have needed it
is that the key I needed well there's no
description on the key which to be fair
he thinks in real life have descriptions
on the keys
so I don't know for certain if that's
just me oh
I was hoping I could do that over and
over again
all right so that's good news there's at
least a little bit of power here
which is pretty cool
any horrible monstrosities in here
hello oh this door not that door this
door
okay
okay no these doors seem to be working
anything behind me
good
long as we're on the same page as long
as we're all on the same page and we
know that nothing is going to be
sneaking up behind me
we're all gonna be totally okay
oh
oh wow hey
how are you
you're
tall or you're floating
even better than being tall
wait a minute look at that thigh gap doe
oh [ __ ] uh anyway how are you Shadow
Demon you good you good
oh good
that was a Bassy lightning Striker boom
great
great
this is
this is a stunner
anyway time to crush this stream like a
crushed purse
am I dead am I dead it's awfully dark
hello oh
yeah that that can't be good that sounds
like someone trying to break in
well I guess I'll go check
foreign
T call the police I'll go downstairs and
look
with my eyeballs
the alarm must be defective
man the
ball the big balls and tiny brain on
this guy here
am I gonna have to turn out all the
lights I bet it's gonna I bet it's gonna
maybe turn out the lights you know what
I'm too brave for lights why did I turn
them on in the first place why do what
this look
ass nothing nothing actually do I need
that key now
I'm like trying to need the key now
no I don't need this and I don't need
you know why do I even have my phone
light it doesn't even do anything but
turn it off I say kill it kill it dirt
lion who needs it get out of here
I can stumble My Way Through The Dark
I'm brave
yeah it's fine what was that sound came
from the first hallway room you mean my
bathroom the bathroom all right you know
what oh I can't turn on lights oh [ __ ]
who's that air
who's in here
who dares
you mean by the first hallway room what
does first hallway room mean
oh [ __ ] this room the one that I
couldn't open before right yeah what was
that
uh [ __ ] here we go
oh
hi
oh
press shift to run
better get the gun and save gun yeah
let's Okay I gotta go get the key oh I'm
going for it baby you can't stop me I
know exactly where the key is wow
[ __ ] didn't think you were gonna come
for me right then and there
all right let's try it again wait no
wrong way let's try it again I didn't
know that you were just flu [ __ ] uh all
right what do I do what do I do what do
I do I how can I get away from you I
don't think I can
ah well it closed the door be the
perfect deterrent oh [ __ ] it didn't
close
sure wish I actually had light hello
where are you
where'd you go
where did you go where did it go oh
there it is okay I guess I didn't see it
but you know I'm just gonna guess that
it was there all right all right I got
the key baby
got the key
let's assume oh oh come on why Wow
oh
not like that where are you open the
door
open the door oh don't close the door
you know what don't even worry about the
door I'm not even worried about the door
anymore you know what screw the door the
doors are overrated I'm gonna shoot this
thing I'm gonna shoot you you're about
to get shot
and I'm sure that this is gonna work
perfectly right Mouse button to shoot
yeah it makes sense
oh now I've got a light
oh now I've got a light
wow
foreign
what did I say what did I say I was
gonna Crush that ghost I was gonna crush
it like a walnut like a watermelon
between my thighs crushed it crushed
that ghost and Crush that sleep feel
great solid eight hours no more no less
every night every night baby that's how
I do
yeah what were you reading your ghost
and some weird
some stupid book for nurse I'm dead
I'm dead
I'm dead and I died good I'm dead proud
I crushed that death
just like I crushed life I don't know
why I was a bro for that one but it just
seemed like that character you know I
don't choose the character the character
chooses me so yeah that was uh true
nightmares not bad no there's something
very scary about
being in bed and your security alarm
going off it's a way that it's like
shown an intruder that has I haven't
seen in other games before and it's
relatable just because it's a very
modern way of knowing like oh [ __ ]
something's in the house yeah but anyway
very cool so that was three scary games
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to play this game for
yourself they are linked in the
description below thank you thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
video there's a like button that lets
you know how much you appreciate me
playing these games please consider
pressing that button I have no idea what
it does but it means the world to me
it's the only number that really matters
and also subscriptions so if you want to
subscribe there is a button for that and
a bell
there's no number tied to the Bell but
hey what if it was what if you can see
how many people rang that Bell but
that'd be pretty cool
what's really low anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more scary games they're
Linked In the description or in the
suggested videos down there click on any
scary game with my face on it
I'm sure it's scary so thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Applause]
[Music]